[موسيقى]
مازن يصرخ من أجل شقيقه الأصغر
أكثر دادا ومحمد علي البالغ من العمر 20 عامًا فقط
تغرق آبار ألم أولئك الذين أحبوه بسبب تراتيل الحداد الشيعية على الراحل
الحزن هنا
على حياة
ضائعة بلا رحمة  تسحق وجهها مغطى كما هو
معتاد بالنسبة لأولئك في الصباح ، لقد
بكت كثيرًا لدرجة أنه لم يتبق لها دموع
عميقة جدًا ، فقد كان اليوم الأول من
المظاهرات مثل الآلاف الآخرين
مرتضى ضاقوا ذرعا بالوضع الراهن
ومستويات الفساد في البلاد.  قلة
الخدمات الأساسية ، كانت البطالة
مرتفعة بشكل خاص بين جيله ،
وكان الرد سريعًا ، وتم
إطلاق الرصاص الوحشي غير المتوقع
على مرتضى برصاصة في صدره ماتادا ماتادا هنا في
الشارع ، لكن هكذا سوف
يتذكره بابتسامته ، حبه
للحياة كان مرتضى يدرسه.
العلوم السياسية كان يحلم بأن يكون ضابطًا في
الجيش العراقي لخدمة بلده
ولم يمنحه أبدًا فرصة في
اليوم التالي ، حيث أظهر له الأصدقاء والغرباء
عندما يموت شخص أو
ستبقى أصواتنا مائة وهم
يهتفون كان واجبنا ابن عمه
يخبرنا قاسم جماعة أن نعود إلى حيث
سقط ، ويقول إنهم جميعًا
طلاب جامعيون وعمال باليومية يكافحون
بين العمل الشاق ودراساتهم ، ووعود
الحكومة بالإصلاح لا تعني سوى
القليل لأولئك الموجودين هنا الذين تعهدوا بأنهم
لن يتم تخديرهم بعد الآن
بالكلمات الكاذبة.  تقسم والدته على الاستمرار
حيث توقف ابنها عن
العاني يا ماشا يا جيمي ، لقد كنت مؤخرتها - يا رئيس لقد
سرقوا صوت ابنها حتى
يستخدم من أحبوه صوتهم الآن
أروى ديمون سي إن إن بغداد